Alright, good evening.
We should meet outside, I think tonight.
That should be beautiful out there.
Um, so this is the, uh, culmination of a
couple, what, 10 week-ish series
called First Things First, which we, he did on Sundays of,
uh, of a limited version of each
of those studies on Sundays preaching, talking through it,
and then coming up on Sunday, on Wednesday nights,
following up with that towards what, uh, some q
and A might be and some additional information that you have
to cut to get it to 30, 35 ish minutes on Sundays.
There is a lot more there, of course.
And so we tried to add that in on Wednesday nights
and get a little opportunity to dig deeper
and understand better.
And then help answer some questions.
So, again, tonight's similar to that as we're gonna go
through a little bit of a review from Sunday,
some additional information,
and then get into q and a about it.
So tonight is, uh, Christian Liberty.
So you might've said, or when you saw that topic come up,
you might've thought, does it have to do
with like America Freedom and things like that?
Well, liberty and freedom are virtually synonymous,
but the idea is, what can we do as Christians
and not do in our faith, not under the law anymore,
but how do we make decisions on
what we can do and what we can't do?
So what we did on Sundays, we worked
through one Corinthians eight and nine
and just walk through the whole couple chapters there.
I referenced chapter 10. I wanna hit a little bit more
tonight, just briefly,
but do wanna walk back through just to remind us of, uh,
what God's word says about this
before we get into, okay, what is liberty freedom?
What is, uh, some of these things,
and probably more specific questions
I would imagine come up.
But the point Paul was writing to the Corinthian church,
of course, was they asked a question about food
offered to idols.
People were sacrificing food
or sacrificing meat
to these idols all over the place in Corinth.
And so people were thinking, well, if I come across
that meat somehow, like if I'm in a market
and just happen to buy some meat
that I didn't know was offered to an idol,
or if I'm at somebody's house
and get offered it, what do I do?
Because some had a sensitive conscience to that.
Other people had a little bit less sensitive conscience
could just say, yeah, fine, we're free.
God called all meat, all food clean.
So what's wrong with eating this?
Versus some people are saying, no, I can't,
I I came outta that world.
Can't do that. Kind of similar to you might say, someone
who was formerly an alcoholic would never go to a restaurant
that serves alcohol or something like
that, or wouldn't wanna go to a party.
That's just because I, I don't wanna be around it
because I I'm so tempted by it.
I might be falling into it again.
Um, so that was the point of
what they're asking Paul here about this
food offered to idols.
And so what he does, he again, starts with in chapter eight,
this idea of how we should be considering each other in the
church, the believers within the church.
First, make sure that we're caring for each other
and, uh, not putting any judgment on each other.
When we have different levels of conscience on some
of these issues, we should not judge each other
for having different levels of conscience on that.
But then also we shouldn't use that for license
and just say, well, I can do whatever I want
'cause this is my conscience.
Saying, well, that could put a stumbling block in front
of someone who might have a, a weaker conscience in that.
Just a different conscience in that.
So considering each other, thinking about our love
for our brothers and sisters in Christ
as one limiting factor in our Christian freedom, what we do
or don't do, like he says in verse 13,
therefore, if any, if food makes my brother stumble,
I will never eat meat lest I make my brother stumble.
Is that our attitude when we think about brothers
and sisters in Christ, that's a love for them,
that I don't want them to stumble.
But then in chapter nine, he does, uh,
a little bit different angle in the same vein
of limiting freedom by saying these things are limited
by our love for unbelievers, how we treat people
who are not believers, and how we live in front of them
and how we live out our faith in front of them.
So he does a long, I didn't, I skipped it on Sunday.
This, uh, verses one through 12
or so plus some into 15 through 18.
But he defends the right, he has
to get financial assistance from the church to be paid
by the church for the gospel ministry.
He performs. He does a lot of different arguments for that,
and it's very well done.
Uh, but he says it again, nevertheless,
we've not made use of this, right?
We endure anything rather than put an obstacle in the way
of the gospel of Christ.
So that's the love for unbelievers that we're end doing,
enduring anything.
And you see Paul do that,
and throughout his ministry, not just,
I'm not gonna get paid like beatings and shipwrecks
and persecutions.
He's like, I'm, I'm taking this face first in so many ways
because of the gospel that I know is going to save some.
So that's his enduring anything, including
that he's not going to take any financial compensation from
the Corinthians because the people
outside the church would see it as a hired hand.
He's just something that he's just preaching the gospel.
'cause he's getting paid for it. It's, it's nothing
that really is his treasure.
He says, no, I, I have the right to, but I'm not going to.
And so we talked about it was we don't have to,
we're not required to employ or utilize
or take advantage of our rights that we have.
Just because you have the right
to do something doesn't mean you have to do that.
I think there's, there's a lot of Americanism bred into us
that we, we have this right?
And so it's almost like it's at all costs.
We defend it and use it.
And Paul's saying, well, maybe we need
to think differently about our rights
and say, Hey, maybe I can set that aside for the sake of
someone hearing the gospel more effectively through me.
And then he also talks about serving those,
becoming all things to all people, talking to the Jews,
the Gentiles, to the weak, everybody.
I became all things to all people that
by all means I might save some.
He's not saving. Remember that
we talked about this throughout this series.
God is the one who saves, but he uses people like Paul
and you and me, that that's what Paul is talking about.
That I might be used to save some, I do it all for the sake
of the gospel that I might share
with those people in its blessings.
That's the idea of serving, giving my life away,
giving my rights away,
and giving my life away, serving, loving so
that unbelievers would see the gospel
and know it better through me.
That takes discipline, uh,
because he says in 24
through 27 about disciplining his body like a
an athlete running a race.
He's wanting to love Christ above all else.
And that means he's got to put things, some,
some decisions in place that help him get there.
Now, before we get to that chart, we're, we'll,
we'll show the chart again in a second,
but I want to go through chapter 10 just briefly
because I, I alluded to this.
The natural reaction to this is that, well, man, I,
I can't do anything If I have to think about believers
and if I have to think about unbelievers, like
I'm not really free then, like, I'm,
I'm just not gonna do anything because it's so restricted
by my love for everybody else.
Well, first of all, let's not be selfish.
Let's not just think about ourselves here.
Uh, Galatians five, I talked
about this morning with the men.
Like Galatians five says, yes, you've been given freedom,
but don't use that freedom as a means for selfish purposes.
Like just to serve yourself.
He says, God's given us his freedom to serve others with it.
And so when we think about, well, I just can't do anything,
can I, uh, so we keep going back to the alcohol.
It's an easy example. But like, well, you're saying,
if I think about believers, that means I can't have a glass
of wine at dinner with any believers
because they're gonna fall into sin
or they're gonna be tempted, or whatever it is.
Or, or unbelievers are gonna think I'm a drunk.
Like, well, so I can't ever have a glass of wine.
Is that what you're saying? Well, no,
but also, let's not be selfish,
but listen to what chapter 10 talks about.
He, he does further explain himself in a way that does get
to that, that there is a place for it.
And this is chapter 10, verses 23 and beyond.
It says, all things are lawful,
but not all things are helpful.
Meaning they're, they're not illegal,
they're not under the law.
You're not under the law anymore. So you can do it,
but not all things are helpful, but not all things build up.
So again, he's still couching this thing of like, yeah,
you can do it, but it's not maybe helpful.
It's not maybe building you up or others up. So be careful.
And then he says, let no one seek his own good,
but the good of his neighbor.
But then he answers the question in verse 25,
eat whatever is sold in the meat market without raising any
question on the ground of conscience.
So he finally answers the question.
He says, yeah, you can eat it.
He'd been talking about it for so long in two chapters.
He says, yeah, yeah, you can eat it
for the earth is the lord's and the fullness thereof.
It's all gods, it's all clean.
If one of the unbelievers invites you to dinner,
you're disposed to go like you.
Yeah, I can go eat whatever's set
before you without raising any question
on the ground of conscience.
So you're at an unbeliever's house,
they're offering you meat that was sacrificed to idols.
You don't even need to ask. You just eat.
They gave it to you. It's clean, you're fine.
So he answers the question, right?
So he, he said, be careful,
be careful, be careful, be careful.
Then he says, no, actually you can, you can eat it.
But he still watch this verse 28.
But if someone says to you,
this has been offered in sacrifice, then do not eat it.
So again, he says it again, don't eat it for the sake
of the one who informed you for the sake of conscience.
I don't mean your conscience but his.
Now, when I studied that, it's assuming
that the person who's saying
that is probably a believer who's got a sensitive conscience
about the the meat, it wouldn't be the unbeliever, right?
The unbeliever offered it to idols, he doesn't care.
But the person who raises a question about it would probably
be a believer that's with you, associated with you.
And they're like, Hey, man, that was offered to, to idols,
and their conscience is weak.
He goes right back to chapter eight, right?
He goes back and he says, Hey, be careful.
Don't cause to stumble.
But then he says this interesting phrase, verse 29,
for why should my liberty be determined
by someone else's conscience?
If I partake with thankfulness, why am I denounced
because of that, for which I give thanks.
So it almost seems like he's going back on his word there.
He just said, yeah, you can eat it.
And then he said, but if somebody raises
a question, don't eat it.
But then he just says, but I I, I can't be fully restricted
by somebody else's conscience,
meaning my life is not dictated by what this person
or that person in their conscience fully believes.
And so he's, he's playing this middle, I think,
where he says, if I partake with thankfulness,
meaning I have given thanks to the Lord
for his provision here.
Why am I denounced 'cause of that, for which I give thanks,
meaning I see this clean and so I can eat it,
and I give thanks to God for, but this person doesn't.
So here, here would be a summary.
He goes on to talk about, do all for the glory of God,
which will get us to the chart here in a second.
But I, I think what he's saying here is
that you're free.
So in this case, you're free to eat the meat.
You just need to be really careful.
As you do, consider others, both believers
and unbelievers, be really,
really careful about whether you should or shouldn't.
And maybe in your context with this unbeliever, you should,
because that would create some weirdness with that person.
But with a believer, you're saying, no, I shouldn't.
Or somebody raises a question. You should be cautious.
You should be giving yourself to them.
But in the end, let that be about 99%
of the decision making process.
The the 1% you have is your freedom to do it.
So that, that's where we get to that reality of that.
I can't stand here with my conscience
again, alcohol, for example.
Like I've got a conviction towards that personally
as a leader, as a father, uh,
based on addictive personality in my past.
I mean, I'm like, I'm staying away from it. Okay?
But again, I can't stand here and say that to you.
Even sitting there in a dinner setting,
I wouldn't hint like, Hey, you need to, you need to stop.
'cause I don't really feel like I should.
So I don't want you to, I can't do that.
So we have to kind of go both ways with this.
I have to consider others in my life
as I'm pursuing decisions.
But then we also need to, this is where the judgmental part
of chapter eight comes in, not go back the other way
and try to restrict everybody else around me
because of my convictions, right?
It works both ways in this unity, it's,
it's mutual submission in that.
Okay, so let's go back to the chart.
You put that up for us, please, and see that up there.
This is the flow chart that we ended with on Sunday,
getting to the areas of freedom.
So again, let's walk through this briefly.
This is, uh, I found this on the internet,
and then our team made it look pretty.
The overarching theme
of everything is do it all for the glory of God.
Everything, every decision, every action, every thought,
do it all for the glory of God.
That will, that will limit us first
and foremost in some big ways.
Then does the Bible allow it?
Find the scripture says, no, don't do it.
Simple, simple.
But if the Bible is silent on it,
like the Bible doesn't talk about Dr.
Pepper. Okay, so does the Bible allow it? Yeah, I guess.
Uh, does my conscience allow it?
Well, then maybe there's a conviction in my own heart
that I shouldn't do this or that, or drink this or that,
or whatever it is.
And if it's there, if it's inside you
and it's there, don't do it.
There's peer pressure. You kind of think of kids, right?
You're, you're feeling pressured to go some way.
It's not just kids, it's adults.
We're peer pressured just as much, but I feel wrong.
I feel con my conscience is wrong.
Ah, I don't wanna do that. Don't do it.
But if you say, yeah, okay, conscience allows it,
then you're in an area of freedom.
But that doesn't mean we just go for it. Hold on.
Here we go. There's a set of further questions here.
And it goes to what we talked about here in one Corinthians.
What's the effect on other Christians?
Is this going to hinder any other believers around me?
Love is more important than knowledge.
That knowledge in one Corinthians eight, right?
Love is more important than that,
that I know I'm free, I can do this.
But love wins over that with believers.
And then the second, what's the effect on non-Christians?
The gospel is more important than our rights.
Again, I don't have to, I apply,
employ my rights in every situation.
You don't have to. Nobody's requiring you to
because the gospel is more important.
But then that last question, what is the effect
of my spiritual life or my family's spiritual life?
Spiritual health is more important than freedom.
What am I doing to foster growth?
Is it gonna help me grow towards Jesus?
Is it gonna stir my affections for Jesus? Or is it not?
I think we don't consider that question very often.
So that was our framework.
And I'm assuming that a lot of our questions will come on
how to apply that, maybe others.
Uh, but that's why I'm gonna bring Steve
and Joe up here with me, elders that will help us to process
through some of these things.
Begin thinking of questions.
Uh, I think we can run some case studies
of this if we would like to.
Uh, but otherwise we were just happy to,
to kind of talk through this.
'cause I know there's, there's a lot
of uncertainty about this.
And I, I mentioned as I was even saying the lists of things
that were sand, you know, and like tattoos and alcohol usage
and, um, plastic surgery and these kinda things.
Like the, there's a list of things
that we would consider third level sand issues.
But the hard part is, okay, how do we apply that?
And even as I said, those that list I was, you, you're the
what abouts were coming up in your mind.
But what about this, well, you said this,
but what about if this happens,
but what about this scenario?
But what about if it, and,
and it can go on forever, so we could be here all night,
but the idea is we wanna help process.
Because the idea of James one talks about needing wisdom.
That's really what this is.
Having the mind of Christ to be able to discern
in the moment, not only what would Jesus do,
but how would Jesus think about this situation?
How would Jesus discern which left
or right way to go here to, to think
through it like he would, that's called wisdom.
And to apply it then into a situation that we're facing.
So we wanna help think through that 'cause.
'cause we're growing in that too.
None of us have a market on this thing,
but we wanna help grow through this together.
And so if you have specific questions, that's
what we're got the mics up here to, uh, to, to look at.
Otherwise, we're gonna have to just riff
and figure out what we get to talk about.
Steve, did you say, what would
Jesus do?
Make sure they're on. Make sure they're on.
Sorry, I don't know if they are. They're on
Like ww JD Yeah.
Yes. Ww Remember the old bracelets, right?
What would Jesus do that was, uh, it's
Not a bad place to Start. It's
a good, good thought process. Yes, for sure.
I don't know. Are they on? They good? Yes. No. So
What would Jesus do?
What would Jesus do? Because
We had those bracelets.
I mean, I had, I had
One. You looked at it right there. Yeah.
Chart. You had one.
Feel free to get to the mics.
We're just kind of talking now.
But what would be a case study?
Let's, let's keep the,
the chart up on the screen if we can please.
And kind of think through what would be a, an example
of a, a way to make a decision.
What's something we could make a decision about before,
or as people are figuring out questions.
It's an example of a way to apply this in daily life.
I'll just say when we, we put that up on Sunday, um,
I thought back to many, many years ago, um,
when my dad would sit down with me
and say, let's talk about how to make a decision.
And so he would get out a piece of paper and a pencil
and he'd say, pros and cons.
And you write down the prose and the cons.
Uh, but honestly, we didn't talk a lot about
spiritual things and how, uh, that prayer would be involved,
that reading scripture would be involved.
But, uh, uh, but a a way of going about
and having an organized way of analyzing issues
before you're making decisions that kind
of brought back memories of that.
And I think that's good.
Obviously, uh, don't know how often we do that.
Um, and then my other question was,
and I'll quit, was that, uh, Paul was talking about, um,
eating meat that was sacrificed
to idols and that type of thing.
What, what's an example of that today?
And so we, what does
that, what's, what are we talking about?
Something like that today? What would that be? Yeah,
Somebody come up with a way, an example.
Think about it. We'd love to hear.
Let's, let's walk through it. Joe, anything?
Yeah. Well, as we were walking in, I, I, uh, told, uh,
a pastor that, uh,
somebody's gonna ask about medical marijuana.
So About What
was somebody gonna ask about that?
Somebody, okay, Joe did.
So we're gonna, we're gonna talk about it.
So how, let's just do it.
Okay. Yeah. Let's work through it.
So how would we work through a decision like that?
Because that's an example. People have to decide
or would decide, should I do this or shouldn't I do this?
And what is my, how would we walk through that?
So does the Bible allow medical marijuana?
Are you asking me? You're asking me asking you, man. Do
You, can you find that? Can you
Find that I cannot find in here where, uh,
that is prohibited Okay.
To be correct. Yes. Okay.
So it's, it's not explicit. Like I mentioned Dr.
Pepper earlier, right? That's not
In there. Yeah. Right.
Okay. So does my conscience allow,
it would be the second question.
Dealing specifically with that.
Does my co would, how would somebody discern if,
if maybe would people be different in that at times?
I think, I think absolutely people would,
would come into it with a, a history
of understanding about the use of, uh, marijuana.
Uh, and it could be very easily something you say,
I absolutely am not going there.
I know too much bad that's happened,
so I'm not going there.
That makes it, that makes it pretty easy.
But then the question is, Steve, what about the person
who I'm, I'm flipping it on you here.
Yeah. What about the person who says, well, it's legal,
so it must be okay, so why not?
Yeah, and I, I think that back in my experience
of working in the city of Evan for so long and being here,
and if someone would've told me that we would have 30
or 40 medical marijuana places in the city limits of Edmond,
uh, 10 years ago, 15 years ago,
however long you wanted to go back,
I was, oh, that's never gonna happen.
Never gonna happen in the state of Oklahoma.
Obviously, wrong. Uh, but I did have a conversation.
I remember when the, the medical
marijuana issue came up for a vote.
I was talking to a person who was a physical therapist,
and they were talking about their patients, people
that they had come into contact with and served and
provided healthcare services that, uh, that
sometimes medical marijuana provided them with relief or
otherwise, they weren't able to obtain that relief.
Now that, that was hard for me to understand.
Uh, but I appreciated their perspective.
Uh, um,
but we've kind of, it seems like sometimes we get way out
of hand with regard to those things.
Um, again, judgment, judging, other people
that gotta be very careful with that.
Uh, and I don't really want, I don't want to go there.
Uh, but again, the, the conscience,
I think I was thinking about that also, you know,
con one man's conscience is different than another man's
conscience or, uh, what, what,
what they feel is appropriate.
Uh, but is there bringing glory to God?
Um, uh, that's, that seems
to be very important to think about.
Um, it's important to me.
God's word says that it has to be that way.
So that's kind of where I end up
as it comes all the way through, isn't
Bringing glory to God.
Yeah. And you have to start
with the fact, is it legal or not?
Mm-Hmm. Right. So, so we're not to break laws, right?
So that would be considered, does the Bible allow it?
You could even couch it in terms of that.
So if it's illegal, first of all,
that's something to think about.
But that just because
something's legal doesn't mean it's right.
Right? Doesn't mean it's good.
Um, but conscience would be a big decision.
That's an area of freedom for some.
But then you have to consider
what is the effect on other Christians.
So there can be some like, reality of thinking, man, if,
if I'm doing this, some other believer's gonna
think the worst.
Now, some of this stuff you will be able
to do completely in the privacy of your home, right?
Nobody will even know.
Okay, so what's the effect on their Christians?
They don't even know. Or
non-Christians, they don't even know.
That's fine. But then number three,
what is the effect on my spiritual life?
Okay? I'm free to do that.
And it may be importantly helpful for someone
who has no other way of means of, of pain relief.
Okay, fine. But is it becoming then,
and this this goes way beyond just this one subject, is
that becoming something
that I'm depending on more than on the Lord?
I'm going to kick some people in the shins with this one.
Coffee can get there,
sugar, I'm talking myself on that one.
Sugar can get there where, and,
and you could fill in the blank
with all kinds of things, right?
Where that third question,
what's the effect of my spiritual life?
I run to Skittles
whenever I feel a little bit down,
or I feel like I need a bit of a, you know,
it's been a hard day.
Fill in the blank right now.
Does it always mean like,
I'll I'll eat Skittles in my life again,
I'm guaranteeing you that, right?
But the reality is, where is that?
And that's, that's digging way
underneath the surface on decisions, right?
That this thing, whatever this thing is, I am depending on
for joy and satisfaction
and life rather than the Lord.
You know, that is interesting
because, uh, in effect that becomes, uh,
an I can become an idol.
And, and that is something you have to watch out for.
Now, here's the other side of that coin is
should we put our judgment on someone
who finds relief using medical marijuana?
Uh, should we judge them? Yeah.
That's another question. Yeah.
And I think one Corinthians eight would say, if it,
if it follows through, it's legal
and all the things like that, and they're,
they're really being careful with it.
Absolutely. Go for it. And we, we should be
Careful. Yeah. I think, yeah.
Yeah.
I, I think that's sort of the caution is imposing my
conscience, uh, on others can be damaging as well. Yeah.
Yeah. And it works both directions. Yeah.
Steve, well, you, you mentioned earlier
the example of alcohol.
We were talking to Galatians five this morning about, uh,
uh, works of the flesh listing them.
Drunkenness was one.
Uh, so if you were under the influence of any kind of drug,
alcohol, or otherwise, uh,
and it altered your, your mind altered your ability,
obviously it's against the law
to be operate in a motor vehicle, whether it's DUI alcohol
or DUI drugs, uh, from what I did for a long time
and prosecuting people for that.
Uh, so, uh, any types of substance, if you had,
it had to be marijuana, it could be anything.
So it ties into the aspect of drunkenness
or things that can, uh, interfere with your ability
to make sound decisions.
And it affects other people too. Yeah.
Yeah. That's good. Got two mics up here.
Nobody's wanting to step up and, and ask.
Okay. So tr is gonna throw, come at us. Okay.
What about open carry? Open carry? Okay.
That's, that's what he said. Okay. Alright.
What about open carry? All right, so let's, let's take it
through the grid right now.
What do you mean? First of all, open carry means, uh, in,
in our context, it means some kind of firearm, not hidden.
It means an open carry of a weapon
of some firearm sort, right?
Am I hitting that, Steve? Is that okay?
I think what most people would believe. Sure. Okay.
So let's think through that. Thank you tr for that one.
Let's do it all for the glory of God, right?
So is can I do that?
Can I open carry to the glory of God?
Yes. Well, you, you've, you've already run, run
through several to get to, to where you're at.
Okay. On your own spiritual health.
So there's still, the question is, is it legal?
Okay. Does the Bible allow it? Does
The Bible allow? Yes. Is
it legal? Yes. Conscience.
Does your conscience allow it? It must be
or you wouldn't want to.
Yeah. Okay. So then the question is, is it,
what's its effect on other believers?
Is that something your conscience?
Here's a question for the theologian here.
Oh, is that something that your conscience decides
What your, what do you mean? You say,
I'm good with it, but then you say you run it
through the filter of what's the effect on other believers?
'cause people are gonna come
to different conclusions about that, I assume.
Yeah,
That would be one Corinthians eight where he's saying, if,
if meat makes my brother
stumble, I'm never gonna eat meat again.
'cause he's loving them more than,
he's like, I, I have freedom to do this.
I know I do, but I'm loving that person more.
So I'm going to sacrifice in some ways my own
conscience, my rights.
So does that mean you shouldn't if some Christians object?
Well, that's where, that's why I wanted to get
to in one Corinthians 10 tonight,
that he said there is a measure of place where, yeah, okay.
But I think we should be careful even with that to say,
well, yeah, I have the freedom too.
And nobody says I can't.
But even just a few people say I can't,
or a less than half say I can't.
Well, where's the line? I, so we've asked here,
so here's an example at our church,
we've asked for no open carry.
We've, I mean, we can't make that a law,
but we've, we've put signs up, say, no open carry.
And that's for the conscience sake of believers
who would be like really wary of that, just being around it.
Now we know people conceal carry, we have security,
we have, we know that's there.
But the open carry is, is a bit of this different step.
So we've just asked here personally not to,
that would be a question for somebody who's saying, no,
I have the right to do that.
You can't tell me I can't do that.
That's, that's where we're starting to get to some
of this heart issue here.
Why is that more important to you than considering what,
what the authorities would say in that scenario
or what, what you are thinking
of other believers in that scenario?
That's where we're getting to with this,
is if your desire is to flaunt, if my desire is
to flaunt a freedom
above loving someone else, that's, that's a problem.
Yeah. That's great.
Yeah. I remember we had, uh, um, couple number
of years ago, um,
4th of July parade's a big thing here in Edmond.
And we had a person that was walking the parade route
with an open carry weapon.
And it made a lot of people nervous and concerned,
and there were certainly within their right to do so,
but how it affected other people was, was of concern.
And, uh, worked through that.
And, and ultimately he,
he let the parade route at one point in time.
But, um, so TR asked about open carry.
Uh, back to my many years ago, the issue was,
can, can you play cards?
Uh, and so, and can you dance
and can you go with girls that do?
And so that was what we were dealing
with in the seventies in my youth group, uh,
at the Baptist Temple Church in Oklahoma City.
Uh, but then when we were at Falls Creek,
we were playing cards spades, we were playing spades,
and we liked to play music.
And people would move,
there would be some rhythmic movement move in
the cabinets at
Falls Creek matching, matching the rhythm
of the song. So that
Was, that was the goal, just happened to, was a goal
anyway, so
No, they weren't,
they weren't matching the, okay, that makes
Sense. So there, that, that
was a,
a very relevant discussion we had as,
as back in my days in the youth group, could you do that?
Um, and we couldn't.
And some felt very strongly that you could not.
Um, and people would get in trouble for doing so,
And we solved that at our house.
We played Rook because it has numerals on the card instead
of the, uh, royal faces.
So,
But So here's, so this, that's a great example.
Uh, we all have grown up in situations of
regulations and rules put on youth groups or whatever.
And, and to some of us, they could feel really arbitrary,
like, why, what's PO cards like?
And so prob part of the problem
is not being given the reasons for
why those decisions were made.
Okay, great.
If that's the decision,
and here's why, let's talk through it.
Alright? But
so many times we grew up in situations where it wasn't ever given.
So you're here, these arbitrary rules, you're like, what,
what in the world, why, why are we not doing this?
It's fun. Like why wouldn't, so I think that's part of
what we're trying to get to here, is let's think
through it biblically.
Not just don't do that, don't do this, do this.
And we don't have a framework of how to make decision.
Albert
John, this is a perspective, rather the questions,
since we're not having a whole lot of questions,
so I'll, I'll share this.
Kathy and I are blessed to have three daughters,
and they all got married within 22 months.
Wow. Tough on dad, but that's a blessing on that.
But anyway, my oldest daughter wanted
to have a dance at her wedding,
and my youngest daughter had a swinging band
at her wedding on that.
But when the oldest, oldest daughter got married,
there was one of the organists at
the church going have whisper.
Did you hear Dr. Franklin's having
to dance at a daughter's wedding?
You kind of hush. You like that there?
Well, I grew up in the f the fifties
and sixties where the Baptist were a denomination of don'ts.
Don't, don't, don't, don't, you, you can throw up there
and rather relationships, which in my opinion,
that drove many people away from the
faith than through the band.
Fortuitously, we've gotten past that.
But anyway, with that background, the youngest daughter
and the oldest daughter had one, had a dance.
And the, the lady who was going out whispering about Dr.
Franks's office, having a daughter having a dance at their
wedding, by the time the third daughter got married had a
swing band, just a wonderful 15 piece swing band on there.
They were fun a lot out there.
She was at there pat feet, you know? Yeah.
Just going with it. So my point is, sometimes in doing
so we can allow people freedom
where they thought they didn't have freedom to doing.
So that's just a little bit different avenue that, uh,
I was unaware of that it's, yeah.
So, uh, instead of being Carol there, sometimes it does
by stepping out, if you've gone through those
and we're good on theory, it does allow people
to have freedom to do so. Yeah,
Absolutely. That's good. That's good.
Alright. Alright. So, um,
Lemme take this out.
So when I look at the chart, I think
that on the first step there tends to be a lot
of maybe debate amongst Christians even about like,
is this allowed in the Bible or is it not?
Is this a sinner, is it not?
And so I'm just gonna drop this example out there.
Should Christians attend gay weddings?
So if we follow the chart, there's no
directive about which weddings we should
or should not attend.
So I'm wondering if you could address that.
Is that a matter of Christian liberty
or can we apply the chart to that
and come to the conclusion that we shouldn't?
Great question. Great question.
That got a, a pastor in trouble.
Could you reach two months ago?
So the question was one example
of the first, first, um, category.
Does the Bible allow it?
There's debate amongst believers at times about whether the
Bible allows this or not.
And so this is sin or this is not sin
and there's differing opinions on certain things.
And so that can even trip us up
before we get down the flow chart.
So this is not the gospel, by the way,
let's just remind this is just a helpful tool,
hopefully helpful tool that doesn't get everything.
It just hopefully gets us down the road.
The specific question was
what about attending a gay wedding?
That's a great question. Did you
want to answer that or, okay.
No, you look like you wanted to answer that.
Um, yeah, David, what'd you? Were you, I think, um, okay. It
Might help. It might help. Yeah.
Wanted speak to It real quick.
Uh, as far as
scripture addressing specifically like tr r's question about
a firearm, they didn't have sig sour 18 round double stack
firearms in Jesus time.
But the intent of the scripture, even with regard to
marriage and relation in terms of the intent
of the scripture may not say specifically
or bear it out specifically,
but the intent of the scripture, like when Jesus said, those
who draw the sword will die by the sword.
The sword was the weapon of choice at that time for, uh,
uh, a weapon that would be used for defense
and obviously a,
a very lethal weapon at that time that was carried.
So the intent of the scripture is where I would probably on
that first, uh, filter, uh, is where I would try
to look really hard at is what scripture's really telling us
by intent based on that time
and how it relates to what we use today for a weapon
or for relations.
So it just adds more complexity to the answer. But
Yeah, That's all.
Yeah, that's a good point. And that, that would be,
does the Bible allow it?
There is a lot underneath that question for sure.
So for example, about this specific example,
does the Bible allow what is being done
in the ceremony?
We would biblically say no.
Uh, that that actual marriage is not God ordained marriage
between a man and a woman, a male and female.
So in that context, the Bible doesn't allow that.
Now the question is, does the Bible allow us to attend that
ceremony of whatever that is?
Well, that would be, I could see where people would say
that's a conscience decision.
But in the context of that first overarching, the glory
of God, so often, this again gets to
that first category of the Bible.
So often he ties his glory through marriage, the example
of marriage, the gospel, Jesus and his bride.
And, and he paints this picture of the glory
shining through that.
So for us as believers
who believe this truth about the Bible saying this is
what marriage is, I would say
that we wouldn't even get past that first box
to attend a wedding that would be contrary to
what we believe the Bible says.
Now, the question I would follow up with, which is what got
a pastor in trouble a couple months ago on this very
subject, is we're not asking should we love
those people involved in that ceremony.
That I don't think is a conscious decision.
I don't think the Bible forbids that.
I don't think that that's an area of freedom.
I think that's a way we're commanded to love
a person made in the image of God no matter
what they're doing, sin issues, those kind of things.
But love does not demand that I agree with everything
that person does or that I affirm what they are doing
or that I support everything they do.
So there's a measure of saying I can love them
and they can know that I love them, even when I choose not
to come to that ceremony.
Hopefully they, they can Now, people will tie affirmation
with love in our culture, all of that.
But, but the reality is my job is to love them.
And for that specific decision,
I cannot affirm that biblically.
So I'm not going to,
and then I'm gonna work the best I can to love them towards
Jesus, his good news in that. So I wouldn't go,
Yeah, I think at the same time, uh, as you might say
that marriage is not an, it's not a marriage,
it's not a biblical marriage.
However, attending the ceremony may be a matter
of conscience for some.
And John has said, well, in his mind, uh,
his conscience wouldn't,
conscience wouldn't allow him to do that.
I believe that's where you made that break.
I think other people could conscience, believers,
conscience could say, I want to go to support
that individual, let them know that I I care for them
without condoning the, uh,
ceremony. So
I actually stopped before the conscience issue.
You did? Okay. I stopped at the biblical side of that.
Okay. And I, I'm, I'm saying it, I,
I think other people might slip as far as attending
as a matter of conscience.
And again, I think that's where you get into,
it's why it's a Christian liberty issue is
'cause different people I think are gonna come
down differently.
But then you have to ask the further questions too.
Yes. What's the effect on other Christians then?
If that's the case, somebody is Mm-Hmm.
Well, other believers are gonna see that
and really be offended by that.
Yes. In fact, on non-Christians, they're gonna think,
I affirm I'm affirming at this good point.
And what's the effect of my spiritual life? Am I slip?
I there's mm-Hmm. So that, that's a tough one. It is.
But that's, so that's why I even stopped before that.
I think it's a biblical thing that says, no, Janie,
Uh, the next one that would come up in our society today
is because many are required
to do this in their work settings or whatever.
Should I agree to call someone
by their preferred pronouns
other than he or her or they,
because scripture is pretty clear starting in Genesis
that God created us male and female.
So do I participate in their delusion
and allow them to continue with that thinking
or in love?
Do I tell them, I'm sorry,
but I don't believe that
and I cannot call you what you are not.
Hmm. That's, thanks, Janie. That's good.
Another great question.
Stepping all into it tonight, aren't we, Steve?
I mean, I, I've become aware
and, uh, just like Janie said that, uh,
for email communications
and there would be, uh, preferred pronouns listed as part
of like the, the signature line and that type of thing.
Uh, and I think that, um, if I was required by my employer
to add something like that, uh, as, as part
of my correspondence, I, I, my, the way I've answered
that question, I haven't been required.
And now I'm retired. So I guess it doesn't matter.
But, uh, I think if my employer told me that I had to do it,
that say that, then I would say, I'm not going to do that.
And then we'll see where the chips would fall.
Uh, and I, I would,
and I've, in business context, I've seen that
and I've always addressed the person, um, by their name, um,
not by a particular pronoun or anything like that.
And, uh, has it been a big issue?
It seemed like it's kind of, at least recently,
it seemed like it kind of died down a little bit in the
business correspondence that I saw.
Um, but that's an excellent question.
I mean, and again, if I was required to do that,
I think I would have to say no.
And that would be probably a,
a line drawing situation for me.
Uh, that's just, that would be how I would handle it.
So, well, that would be my response as well.
But, uh, I wouldn't condemn someone
if they were in under an authority at work.
And they're required to do that.
I, I don't think the Bible demands, uh, that they resign,
uh, or, or that they refuse to.
Uh, it's a, it's an artifice that allows, uh,
people to, uh,
describe themselves as something they're not.
That's confusing.
And it's not in alignment with God's order. Mm-Hmm.
Uh, but I think there is the issue
of whether you're under someone else's authority, uh,
and they're requiring that.
Yeah. But there might be a time where you feel like,
I need to, I need to take a stand in that and,
and I'm gonna lose my job because of it
Could be.
Okay. Well, So, so is it loving
on our part to not
speak the truth to them in a loving way?
Because when we fail to speak the truth
and allow them to believe these lies,
it's detrimental not only to their physical health,
but also to their spiritual health
and their emotional health.
Yeah. I think there's a measure of
relationship needed.
Um, Jesus didn't address everything he faced.
Uh, you would see Paul walking through Athens.
He didn't call out everything he saw.
So there's a measure of I think
watching when God brings an opportunity to do that.
And I'm pretty sure in our context that somebody in, in
that scenario, they've heard that before.
Now maybe it wasn't done in love, right?
That would be the goal. But they, they've heard the truth,
uh, of, of what they've,
and probably have rebelled against it in some ways.
So, can I love them differently
in a way that allows me the opportunity
to have the opportunity to share that,
uh, that's, that's tough.
There's a lot of coldness, standoffishness in that.
But we don't have
to speak up about everything.
'cause if we did, we'd be constantly on social media,
constantly doing every, I mean,
it would be a blast all the time.
That's where wisdom comes in.
Where does God want me to speak up in this situation?
Do I have an opportunity? Do I have a relationship?
Do we have trust? Is there a way to to address that?
Then that would be a much more likely.
Um, I'm not a big fan
of people standing on the corners and protesting.
That's, that's just, I don't think that is
what God intended.
Um, but I do think there's a measure of speaking the truth
and love when there's a relationship there
and there's an opportunity that they know I care about them
because I've shown it to 'em for however long.
Yeah. It's tough though. That's a really hard one.
Yeah. I, I have difficulty, um,
affirming delusional thinking,
because I'm thinking of this from a psychology background.
Yeah. Secondarily, yeah. Or a spiritual background first.
But then from a, a psychology background, secondarily,
Sure, there's things in my life I've had to come to,
I've heard it over and over again,
but there's things I've had to grow into understanding.
And it took the Lord's change.
Not, I heard it 25 times from somebody,
or people along the way.
It took me some, a seed planted here, seed planted there,
and then finally at Boer Fruit 10 years later.
So there could be a measure of that. So Joe,
You had a, I'm gonna pull this up.
It's a little low. Uh, so you had pointed about,
talked about it earlier, about the line drawn.
Um, and I can't think of a specific example exactly.
I think maybe you'd see it more in a closer group
of like friends of believers.
Um, but what if you get into a situation where one group
or one side of your friends might be offended
by you making one decision,
or it may be guilty on their conscience if you make one
decision, and then the latter the other way,
or the vice versa.
The other way is you there if this other group is offended
or it's guilty on their conscience, if you,
and so you're kind of at that crossroads of like, who do I,
you know, what side do I pick?
You're stuck between, you're going
to offend somebody either way.
Is that what you're saying? Yes, exactly. Oh man.
That, okay. You may
Be by yourself for a while.
Sorry. Uh, I, I, I think there's a measure of,
if, if this is a circle of Christian friends, that's
where a conversations need to happen, right?
If that's where a decision is gonna split the group,
like hold up, like, let's, let's talk about this.
Why do we, why do we feel so strongly about this issue?
And it's a, it's not, number one, it's a conscience issue.
Like, why are we so strong? What is happening here?
Let's just tone it down. Let's calm it down. Let's talk.
Where do we see this in God's word?
How can we make a decision? How can we give
to each other instead
of feeling I'm in the right and all that?
So I think that could happen hopefully in a context
that you're describing.
And it may end up that that turns
that this group ends up here and this group ends up here.
And that's fine. Um, Paul and Barnabas
and John Mark, they had a different perspective and well,
And there are different denominations for reasons that,
uh, aren't big rocks.
Yeah. But do not, this is Romans 1420.
Do not for the sake of food, destroy the work of God. Right?
The work of God is the church. Unity.
Don't for the sake of food
or for conscience, destroy the work of God.
We gotta be over caring,
loving each other. So, go ahead.
I would just add to, um,
what the young lady said a little bit ago about, um, whether
or not to affirm somebody
using pronouns and things like that.
Even, even, even what this young man said,
I would just go right back to one, do it all for the glory
of God in regards to creation.
We start there.
And then secondly, you know, does the Bible allow us to lie?
And it seems like it ends there, you know, so in regards to,
you know, loving the person and, you know,
and kind of affirming it for a while,
'cause you're afraid to lose your job or whatever.
That's, that's all humanly understandable. Absolutely.
But in regards to, does the Bible allow us to lie in an,
as an answer to somebody like that?
I think, I think we have to end it there,
but that, that's just something I wanted to
add to what she was saying.
We can't lie to the person. Good point.
That's not loving them either. Yeah,
That's a good point.
So this, this is where you get to some of the,
the ethical decisions that they talk about in seminary.
They put this before you
and like, so would you, uh, Nazi Germany, you know,
these people are hiding below the,
the floor boards, soldiers come in.
Anybody here yes or no?
Don't. Yes. It's hard. And, and so yeah, it makes sense.
And maybe you say, I'm gonna trust the Lord.
Yes, they're here and then they don't see 'em somehow.
Right? Somehow God does his work. I don't know.
Uh, these are, this is why this is so hard. Yes, absolutely.
Tr another one. I think, well,
A couple of comments.
Uh, one just, we focused a lot on offending other people.
And I think the more important question, not
that we should say, we don't care if we offend people,
but to think about in this scenario of a group of people
who might be offended, it'd be, is
that gonna cause those other people to stumble, right?
Is, is my choice one way
or the other relative to a Christian liberty issue,
gonna cause another believer to stumble in their faith,
somebody who might be younger or less mature in their faith.
That's where I think that would be the litmus test for me,
more than are they gonna be offended
or not, not that we shouldn't consider it,
but we want to consider more what their spiritual
walk might be affected by that.
And, and I don't know,
I just a little bit different take on the,
on the pronoun issue.
I think it depends on the context of relationship.
And I'm really glad John said that.
Um, and I face that at Mike, I work as a physician.
And so I have patients that come in
and they choose how they, like,
they can write down how they would like.
And so that's someone
who I don't previously have a relationship with, right?
And so I can choose at that point to say, well, I'm gonna,
uh, go against your wishes and,
and immediately break that relationship.
Or I might step into that a little bit with
what they preferred in an effort to build a relationship.
And I had that example happen just today.
And so there are times of, if someone comes to me
and they say, I'm, I want you to call me
by a different pronoun now
because I I've known you for 30 years,
but I'm changing who I am.
That's a place to say, well, no. Right?
But if it's somebody who you're starting a relationship
with, there might be an avenue, I think, in an effort
to build that relationship to say, okay, that's, that's
where that person is right now.
Like the woman at the, well, I'm gonna love
that person first and then address their sin second.
There might be, there might be a space for that.
That's good. Okay.
Anyway, I, I hope I can put my thoughts together.
But I, you know, the, the Bible says anything
that's not a faith, it's sin.
And we've gotta start with the scriptures.
And there was a pastor
that I ran into years back,
and he showed me, you can read the Bible in 30 days.
And when you do that month
after month, he said, something will happen to you.
And I'm not gonna tell you, you call me what it is
and everything you do, scripture will come to your mind.
And I had a young man back home, I'm from Texas,
he was 25 years old, been in prison, just got out,
became a Christian in prison.
He had never heard the name Jesus.
And I was helping him work on his house.
And I was telling him about that.
He said, look, I thought I was going to impress him.
You know, about you can read the Bible in 30 days.
'cause everybody says that's impossible. It's not.
He said, let me tell you, when you're in prison in El Paso,
Texas, and you're scared for your life every day,
you read it in three days.
And he could tell me the differences in the translation.
And I think the whole thing is the more we put the word
of God in our life
and the spirit works through us, he's going to tell us what
to do in every situation.
Now, we're not perfect, and I'm definitely loud.
I'm glad y'all don't follow me and go watch me tomorrow.
But our answer is, God, it is not us.
And what other people think.
If there was an example of another preacher,
and he was talking about this guy had two dogs, a black one
and a white one, and he would take 'em to town every,
every week and fight 'em.
And everybody would bet.
And he had, and every week he'd be the last one
bet he always won.
And everybody finally asked him,
how come you always know who he win?
Who wins? And he said, it's
because it's the one I feed that week.
If we're not feeding ourself in the word of God,
the world is going to win.
And that's a daily struggle that we fall, that we do.
The only way God really speaks to us through his word,
and we depend on the Holy Spirit to lead our life, anything
of ourself is look at me.
You know, it's not good. And anyway, I hope I make sense.
Oh, that's good. That's good. Yeah. That's all over.
Uh, Proverbs, the way of wisdom is, is the words,
uh, even personifies the words in that.
All right. So I want to end with this.
This is a, a little snippet of an article
that I found today.
Uh, and it goes back to this conversation about our rights
and what we, what we can do, what we feel the rights
to do, all of that.
And we, we've talked about it in such a way
that it's kinda like, man, I gotta give up my
rights for the sake of others.
All of that, okay, listen to this.
It says, it's not that rights don't matter, they do.
But to follow Christ means to see allegiance to him
as more significant than any right?
We hold in this life with Christ
and his example ever before us.
Our view should be distinctly different from the rest
of human civilization because of the word
and the spirit in this.
A w Tozer once said, few sites are more depressing than that
of a professed Christian defending his supposed rights
and bitterly resisting any attempt to violate them.
Such a Christian has never accepted the way of the cross.
The stories of our persecuted brothers
and sisters around the world ought to remind us that we live
by grace, not by rights.
To be a Christian is to recognize
that the only thing we have a perfect right
to is the wrath of God.
And that's not a right. We want to insist on keeping
God is at work in the heart of his children,
replacing our preoccupation with hanging onto our positions
and rights with an aspiration to empty ourselves.
And when we aim to empty ourselves,
our ambition will reflect John the Baptist's desire
to see Jesus increase in the master's realm.
Its only right that it should be this way.
So God, we pray tonight in light of that,
that we would accept the way of the cross.
There are hard decisions we have to make some really
culturally relevant conversations that we've had tonight,
things that press very directly on us
and may even only increase in the future.
So may we learn from these persecuted brothers
and sisters that we, we live by your grace.
We are sustained by your word.
We are filled with your spirit.
And that wisdom is what we need, what we live by,
what we ask for.
That we would not be double-minded in all our ways,
unstable, but we would be instead filled with that wisdom
of your spirit, your word saturating our minds
that we would know the right thing to do by faith.
And I pray God for grace for one another
as we walk Lives that
are in such different context that our consciences are,
are affected by our history, by our experiences,
by our present.
All of these things affect us so differently.
So God, when we, when we see the big rocks,
God give us unity that is rock solid, unified,
aligned, but on the sand, Lord,
give us grace for one another.
May we seek ways to love
and to not put a stumbling block.
May we look for ways to support and to grow each each other.
But Lord, ultimately we, we want is you.
We want you God, And we need you.
So I pray that we would walk in a way that is worthy
of the calling to which we've been called
to maintain the unity of the spirit
and the bond of peace with all humility, gentleness,
patience, forbearance, knowing that we are on different
places along this pathway, towards christlikeness.
All of us are further along than we were
just a few years ago.
We've all grown and changed and developed.
And, and God, that's your work.
So give us grace for those who are where we once were.
Give us grace for those
who are further down the road than we are.
Because God, all we look forward
to is the day when you finish this work
that you promised you would finish, that you'll bring
to completion on the day of Jesus Christ.
This work you began in us.
So God, give us courage to stand where we need
to give us hope when we are hit with hard things.
I pray that we be the body of Christ together to support
and encourage and lift up
and stand with as we have to make hard decisions, as we have
to stand against the current of the world.
That this would be a fortress, a safe place.
These people would be our family.
Family that lasts forever with you as our father,
Christ as our brother.
Thank you God for tonight. Thank you for the series.
God, what a gift it's been to my soul
and to our pray to our church.
Uh, thank you that you've brought us this far
and I pray you continue to move us forward for your glory.
In Jesus' name, amen. Amen.
Thank You'all, love you more than you know.
Couple resources here.
Come ask questions, but uh, otherwise, see you Sunday.
We are sent.